located in northeastern Jordan near the
Syrian border the names of those
soldiers who lost their lives were
Sergeant William Rivers specialist
Kennedy Sanders and specialist biona
Moffet all of whom were assigned to the
718th engineer company a US Army reserve
unit based out of Fort Moore Georgia
these three fallen heroes were deployed
to Jordan in support of operation
inherent resolve and the International
Coalition working to ensure the lasting
defeat of Isis
these Brave Americans and their families
are in our prayers and the entire
Department of Defense Mourns their loss
we also pray for the speedy recovery of
those who are injured eight Personnel
who received injuries required medical
evacuation from Jordan to the Baghdad
diplomatic support center three of those
patients are scheduled for imminent
transport to lanol Regional Medical
Center for follow on care the other five
have been assessed for mild tbis and are
expected to return to duty
we are still assessing what happened and
how a one-way attack drone was able to
impact the facility us Central Command
continues to investigate this attack and
for operation security and force
protection reasons we're not going to
discuss further specifics or measures
we're taking to prevent such actions or
future attacks but we do know that
iran-backed militias are responsible for
continued attacks on US forces in the
region and as the president and the
secretary have stated we will not
tolerate continued attacks on American
forces
and we will take all necessary actions
to defend US military men and women
forward deployed and we will do so at a
time and place of our
choosing now over the weekend the
secretary received regular updates on
the attack against US forces and
participated in a briefing with the
president and his National Security team
today secretary Austin returned to work
at the Pentagon this morning he hosted
the NATO Secretary General for a
bilateral meeting where they discussed
the war in Ukraine the next NATO Summit
and ways to further strengthen trans
trans Atlantic security he also met with
President Biden at the White House and
later today will host again the the NATO
Secretary General alongside secretary
blinkin and the National Security
adviser Additionally the secretary is
tentatively scheduled to visit Walter
Reed National military Medical Center
this evening for a follow-up appointment
as his doctors said in their statement
on Friday secretary Austin continues to
recover well and is expected to make a
full recovery following his treatment
for prostate cancer and with that I'd be
happy to take your questions thank you
Lita uh thanks Sabrina a couple things
number one uh since secretary Austin has
now returned to the building can you
tell us whether or not uh we will be
able to see him in the briefing room
this week I don't have oh sorry go ahead
you want to get that first go ahead sure
I don't have an update just yet but uh
something that we're certainly working
towards and we'll keep you updated okay
and then secondly uh can you give us an
update on the number of wounded and any
breakdown between Air Force and army on
that and also any update on the
perpetrators of the attack a there's
been a lot of chatter about KH can you
tell us whether that is the leading
suspicion right now sure so on the um
number of injuries right now we assess
that there are more than 40 that have
been injured um we do expect that number
to continue to fluctuate as uh our
service members as you know with TBI
report symptoms later on so that number
could continue to grow um in terms of um
attribution for the attack uh we know
this is an irgc backed uh militia uh it
has the footprints of katab Hezbollah um
but not making a final assessment on
that um our our teams here are
continuing to do the analysis but we
know that um Iran is behind it and um
certainly as as we've said before here
in this in this briefing room um Iran
continues to arm and equip these groups
to launch these attacks attacks um and
we will certainly hold them responsible
just clarification you you said you know
Iran is behind it you know that
Iran and our Iranian leaders were
actually behind this attack as in
planned coordinated or directed it we
know that Iran certainly plays a role
with these groups they arm and equip and
fund these groups I don't have more to
share on in terms of an intelligence
assessment on uh if uh leaders in Iran
were directing this attack but what I
can tell you is that um we know these
groups are supported by Iran um and
therefore they do have their
fingerprints on this but I can't tell
you more in terms of who directed the
attack Jen Sabrina did this drone take
off from an irgc base in Syria uh I
don't have more on the point of origin
just yet of where this attack originated
from and was it human error that failed
to recognize that this was an Iranian
drone coming to the base it's something
that um Central Command is looking into
to find out exactly what happened um as
I mentioned at the top um they're doing
the assessment on this they're working
through what they need to do to um make
sure our service members whether being
in Jordan Iraq and Syria are further
protected um but I just don't have more
to share at this time lastly what kind
of drone struck the base is this the
same kind of Iranian drone being used by
the Russians in Ukraine um that's
something that we're looking at right
now we're assessing the Drone but I
don't have more to share just yet Dre
just to follow up you said Iran was
behind the attack so what does that mean
have you seen evidence of financing or
directing anything specific to this
attack not just generally but
specifically uh so maybe I need to
clarify further um from what Lita had
mentioned we know that Iran funds these
groups like katab Hezbollah we know that
these irgc backed militias are the ones
responsible for attacks on our troops in
Iraq and Syria uh beyond that we're
we're doing an intelligence assessments
we don't have I don't I can't give you
today that this attack linking it to
Iran we just know that Iran funds these
groups like katab Hezbollah and other
groups that have attacked our forces but
I don't have more to share on you're
saying right as a general matter yes and
the second thing is um you've talked
about how the conflict is contained the
Gaza uh Israel conflict is contained now
that US troops have been attacked in
another country are you willing to say
that the conflict is no longer contained
and it's spreading I wouldn't say that
the conflict is spreading in that we've
seen over 100 attacks on US forces
unfortunately over a 100 attacks on US
forces in Iraq and Syria and of course
now in Jordan um we don't want to see a
widening of this conflict we don't see
this conflict widening as it Still
Remains contained to Gaza but this
attack was certainly escalatory in that
it killed three service members three of
our US service members and um as the
president has said uh we don't see
conflict we don't want to see a widen
wide a widening of a regional War um but
we will respond at a time and place of
our choosing it's not spreading when
troops literally have died in another
country yeah well again but they've also
been launching these attacks since
October 17th and again we can't discount
the fact that these attacks are
incredibly dangerous put our service
members at risk but they have not uh up
until yesterday inflicted lethal harm um
they have been predominantly minor
injuries and minor in uh minor damage to
infrastructure yeah Missy want to ask if
if you could uh address the broader
trajectory for American forces in Iraq
and Syria and will these attacks um
affect the ongoing discussions between
the United States and the government of
Iraq about the future of the American
presence there or you know there have
been some reports that the United States
is reviewing plans for the future true
presence in Syria um can you can you
talk about uh how this will or will not
impact that on those deliberations I
think what you're referring to the
higher military commission that we
discussed last week um so we're focused
on working with our Iraqi partner
Partners regarding how to respond to the
attack that um claimed uh three US
service members uh we remain committed
to the HMC process um and will continue
to focus on it at the appropriate time
um I don't have anything to preview on
troops levels or changes in Iraq in
Syria but we are committed to the HMC
process and that is ongoing I mean but
could you just say I mean would I be
right to say that this um lethal attack
on American forces um and the potential
for response which you know President
Biden has kind of foreshadowed
explicitly um would you say that it will
not have an impact on us plans for the
true presence in Iraq and Syria or is it
too soon to say that well I think it's
too soon to say that and also I would
say that you have to remember that the
HMC was already happening and was
something that was announced back in
August of 2023 the attacks on o October
7th did delay some of those
conversations from happening and the
discussions um uh from starting with HMC
but we're still committed to that
process we're still committed to working
with the Iraqi government um and we are
going to continue to do so but I don't
have anything more to preview on what
that means for our our Force levels yeah
Megan can the Pentagon confirm any of
the reports that the reason the Drone
wasn't shot down is because the troops
on the ground thought that it was a
returning American drone yeah I've seen
those reports again that something that
Central Command is assessing right now
but I don't have more to share at this
time so to follow up on that you say
that this is escalatory because troops
have now died um in these attacks but
it's not a spread even though it
happened in a different country is there
any indication that this attack either
the equipment or the way it happened any
of
that was a different kind of attack than
what we've been seeing in Iraq and Syria
or was it simply an escalation and
people died because they weren't able to
shoot it down they didn't detect it the
way that they are in Iraq and Syria to
my knowledge there was nothing different
or new about this attack that we've seen
in other uh facilities that house our
service members unfortunately this
attack was successful but we can't
discount the fact that other attacks
whether it be Iraq or Syria um were not
intended to kill our service members it
is a true tragedy that three of our
service members died um and of course
Central Command is looking into what can
be done when it comes to our air
defenses and looking into this incident
to determine how best we can move um or
best we can further uh strengthen our
air defense systems was this base less
well protected than other bases in Iraq
and Syria not to my knowledge J thank
you can you talk a little bit more about
what this unit was doing in Jordan and
also you have said that Iran has backed
these groups which have launched these
attacks is this attack that has killed
three service members an active War by
Iran well look I think I said this in um
earlier we don't seek a war with Iran we
don't seek to widen this conflict we
have said and we will continue to call
out uh the fact that Iran does fund and
equip these D these groups and provide
them the capabilities that they use to
attack our service members whether it be
Iraq Syria or Jordan um so we're not
going to hesitate in calling that out um
but we certainly don't seek a war and
frankly we don't see Iran wanting to
seek a war with the United States um we
are there in Iraq and in area and um the
I think your original question was um
what were the service members doing
there they are there in support of the
defeat Isis mission that is their
purpose there they are part of a named
Operation um that this that uh this
department has and is committed to in
both in Iraq and Syria um and so yeah
I'll just leave it at that if I could
follow up how is this not a regional War
now between the United States and
Iranian proxies in Yemen Iraq Syria and
now Jordan we're not discounting that
tensions are high in the region by any
means uh since October 17th we've seen
repeated attacks on US forces so we're
not discounting the fact that tensions
are high that these Iranian back groups
are targeting our military members with
the intention of trying to kill them um
but we don't seek a war we don't want to
see this widen out into a a broader War
um and that's you know again attacks on
our service members happening in Iraq
and
Syria to bring it back and to look at
what's happening in the Red Sea we don't
seek a wider War there either but we are
going to respond when it comes to
commercial ships or our ships or um our
partners vessels being targeted and
therefore jeopardizing international
trade and putting at risk innocent
Mariners um so again we don't seek war
but we will take action um and respond
to attacks on our forces uh yeah Janie
thank you two Cas one in North Korea one
in Russia and the North Korea another
submarine launched the Cru missile into
the East Coast yesterday do you assess
that North Korea's continued negative
actions will lead to vital military
action yeah thanks Janie so we're
monitoring these activities and we won't
comment on intelligence uh but we've
been very clear on the threat posed by
the dprk uh and their military programs
and our commitment to the Republic of
Korea and Japan and continues to be
Ironclad Russia Russian defense Ministry
spokesman criticized the United States
saying that the US is dragging South
Korea into the Ukraine
conflict then he wared that if South
Korea sported the Ukraine he would stop
relations with South Korea yeah I think
quite to the contrary uh you see
countries all around the world
supporting Ukraine's cause in the fight
for their democracy and the fight for
their Sovereign territory uh we're
coming up on the two-year anniversary of
Russia invading Ukraine uh Russia is
seeking help from Partners like Iran
like North Korea to continue to fund
itself or support itself in its war
against Ukraine uh and you're seeing
like-minded Nations like the United
States and other countries stand in
Alliance in support of a democracy and
in support of a sovereign country who
was invaded by its neighbor unjustly
invaded uh by its neighbor and um we're
very proud of the Coalition that we've
built in support of
Ukraine what What's the total number of
attacks now since October and the total
number of
injuries yeah just a sec here so um from
October 17th to January 29th uh we are
tracking approximately 165 attacks
that's 66 in Iraq 98 in Syria and of
course the the one yesterday in Jordan
oh and I'm sorry and on injuries um I am
tracking
approximately um 80 US Personnel have
received non-serious injuries since the
attacks began and then how have there
been any attacks today and where uh
there I believe there was an attack
earlier today I don't have the exact
location we can get you that um I I
don't want to speculate but we we can
get you that information after yes right
over here thanks um you said said just
above 160
attacks just this month there's been a
little over 50 so there had been around4
or 15 from October I guess 17th to the
end of last year so and you guys have
respond the department has the US has
responded to a few of these
attacks but the you know in order to
deter and that came out in statements
from from the secretary and from other
us officials these attacks have
continued now they've you know they've
escalated not just into the Red Sea now
to Jordan a third country um the
deterrence does not seem to have worked
yet is the department considering
altering or reviewing its policy in
order to you know to deter these Iran
back militias from from injuring it or
killing more US troops yeah that's
ultimately a decision that the president
is going to make um and as you as I read
out earlier he has convened his National
Security team uh you know frequently
within the the these past few days um
I'm not going to get ahead of any
decisions that the president and the
secretary make on this together um but
certainly as our statement said
yesterday we are committed to uh
responding and we will do so at a time
and place of our choosing just a second
on on to go to Israel and Gaza um
reports in recent days suggested that uh
the Biden Administration including
officials from the Pentagon have become
more and more frustrated with the
civilian death toll and there are
considerations of reviewing what types
of we weapons uh weapon sales to uh to
review those to Israel I know
F separate part of state department but
is the Pentagon does the Pentagon share
that assessment does the Pentagon share
that frustration of uh too many civilian
casualties and go I think we've been
pretty clear that um we don't want to
see any innocent lives lost in this war
and we've been very clear both publicly
and privately with our Israeli
counterparts that um
innocent lives need to be protected
humanitarian corridors need to be opened
humanitarian aid needs to continue to
flow through um of course we're
concerned by the right the by the death
toll in Gaza um we don't want to see
continued Palestinians uh get caught in
the crossfire and um we've continued to
urge Israel uh to protect those innocent
civilians and we'll continue to do so
will um clarification on the on the um
number of injured the 80 includes those
from the most recent attack or not it
does not I'm sorry okay um and then has
U has Tower 22 that facility been
targeted previously either during the
Israel Hamas war or prior to that in
recent years I I can't speak to before
October 7th um but since October 17th
when these attacks have happened um no
uh Tower 22 as to my to my knowledge has
not been the target but as you know uh
there is the G the altom Garrison is
right on that border so attacks have
come pretty close um to Tower 22 but
nothing that has landed on the Jordanian
side um impacts have always been on the
Syrian side except for the attack that
happened yesterday great Natasha thanks
abina so previous drone and Rocket
attacks that have struck or landed near
Military facilities in Iraq and Syria
they have not caused anywhere near as
much damage nowhere near as many
casualties is there an assessment of why
this particular drone caused so much I
mean over 40 people injured three killed
what was different about this drone or
what was different about the facility
that it didn't have the kind of
protection the other bases do I think
what was different about this attack is
where it landed it did impact in um
where living quarters are and I believe
so I believe it was uh pretty early
morning so people were actually in their
beds when the Drone impacted um but in
terms of I mean we've seen these types
of attacks before uh we're certainly
that's that's something that Central
Command is looking into on how they can
better refine not only our air defenses
but prevent future attacks like this
from happening again yeah can I just I'm
going to go over here and then come back
yeah hi a couple of questions um ascom
does this review in the interm are there
tactics techniques or procedures being
changed to prevent this from happening
again in the region yeah I wouldn't
forecast that from the podium here
wouldn't want to get ahead of anything
and how about back door Channel
discussions with Iran anything through
the Swiss government at this point or I
don't have anything to preview here yeah
f
um do you also have a number for the
attacks in the Red Sea and the Gul of
Aiden the most recent um let me see here
if I do I don't know that I
have let me get let me we can take that
question and get back to I just don't
have the running total here as you know
there were um as recently as Friday
there was another attack at a commercial
vessel that was transiting um so happy
to get you those numbers okay and one
more just on the secretary's meeting
with stolzenberg did they about
contingencies and the event that the
Ukraine Aid doesn't go through or can
you talk about the the strategy I
believe we'll have a a larger readout
but of course um something that is top
of mind for the secretary and for many
folks across the administration is
securing that supplemental funding from
Congress uh we have not been able to
supply Ukraine with the PDA since
December since late December uh Ukraine
is uh quite literally in the fight for
its life as it continues to hold
territory and continues to fight for its
Sovereign territory um and push the
Russians back in the um in the East and
the South um so we're going to continue
to urge Congress to pass a supplemental
budget and to give us the funding that
we need to um start those PDA packages
but uh of course it's top of mind for
everyone anything things you can do
without it no not right now yes yeah
thank you you you mentioned that the
kabah has some print of that attack and
you know kah is a part of the popular
mobilization group and it's part of the
Iraqi defense system
so have you get engaged with the Iraqi
government specifically on that attack
on the attack that happened on our
service members I don't have anything to
read out yeah when when you check that
you are not looking in a war with the
Iran does that mean that the Iran is not
in a table when you are thinking and
assessing to responding to that
attack I'm sorry I don't necessarily
understand the question are you taking
Iranian iry as an option to responding
when it comes to responding this attack
that happened yesterday we're going to
respond as the president said and the
secretary has said at a time when we
feel that we that we need to respond I'm
not going to get ahead of the president
or any decisions we don't seek a wider
conflict with Iran we don't want to go
to we don't want a war with Iran again
these are Iran proxy groups launching
these attacks on our service members but
uh we certainly don't seek a wider
conflict but we also own the clock here
and we will respond at a time and place
of our choosing yeah oh I'm gonna sorry
will go over to you thank you if Iranian
prises carried out the attack and do you
do you hold Iran accountable for the
attack and what what uh like um response
would be uh as a as a retaliation
against this attack so as you can
appreciate I'm not going to forecast
what our response looks like but of
course we hold Iran responsible as they
are supporting these groups these groups
that continue to inflict uh casualties
on our forces whether it being Jordan
Iraq or Syria um we absolutely hold Iran
responsible because we know that they
fund and train and support and equip
these militias that operate in Iraq and
Syria So yeah thank you so it is the uh
position of the department that Iran is
responsible for the attack that killed
three US soldiers in Northeast Jordan
Iran Bears responsibility because it
funds these groups that operate in Iraq
and Syria that launch attacks on our
service members understand that but this
attack led to the death of three service
members is Iran responsible for the
death of these three service members
that you just read their names and their
families have been notified of their
death again Iran certainly Bears a
responsibility as they fund these groups
that continue to use capabilities that
they get from Iran uh and of course
killed three of our service members can
I take just a step back sure um and just
looking at last week maybe from Saturday
of last week up
until uh Saturday Saturday of last week
just yeah or Sunday maybe this nine days
um the US launched uh strikes in Syria
in Iraq against hthi positions inside
Yemen with the aim of reestablishing
deterr and degrade capabilities of
whether attacking US forces or shipping
in the Red Sea nonetheless as uh
throughout those days what we saw is
unprecedented uh escalation uh an Assad
was targeted with ballistic missiles
Euphrates site was Target with a drone
more US soldiers were injured uh the
houthis went after a British uh ship
after a US ship it seems to me does the
Pentagon think its approach to
deterrence is firing back is it
successful would you say it's successful
especially when three soldiers were
killed well I mean we are assessing what
happened yesterday and we are trying to
figure out how a one-way attack drone
was able to evade air defenses and was
able to kill three of our service
members and injured dozens more um to
your question on
deterrence I can continue to say we
don't seek war we don't seek further
conflict we don't want to see this widen
out into a regional conflict but we will
continue to do whatever we need to when
it comes to protecting us forces and our
Coalition partners and innocent Mariners
transiting the Red Sea um we believe
that we have been effective in degrading
their capabilities and disrupting their
ability to launch certain attacks um but
the reality is yesterday unfortunately
they were successful and they killed
three of our service members and that
um is an absolute tragedy um I'm going
to go to the phones and then I'll come
back in the room uh Laura saligman
Politico thanks Sabrina I have a couple
questions can you say whether there's
been any decisions made to send any
additional air defenses or other forces
to the region to beef up some of the
counter uas capability here yeah thanks
Laura I just wouldn't uh I'm just not
going to get ahead of any decisions that
uh are going to be made and certainly
wouldn't preview um the repositioning of
any air defenses do we have sufficient
counter drone capability in the region
to account for all the different bases
that are have come under attack
recently yeah thanks Laura I mean again
uh we have seen repeated attacks on our
US service members in both Iraq and
Syria and a majority of the time our air
defenses have been incredibly successful
and you've only seen uh minor damage to
infrastructure and of course um some
some injuries which we all take very
seriously but uh for the most part our
air defenses have been robust and have
been successful I'm going to take one
more from the phone here uh Heather
usnii
thanks so much um the houthi houthi
leadership announced that they fired a
ballist or fired a naval missile at uh
lwis B polar in the Gulf of Aiden I was
wondering if there's any confirmation uh
from the Department of Defense on
whether that happened and if there's any
damage um or if the polar shot it
down uh thanks Heather I don't have
anything for you at this time I'm happy
to we're happy to get back to you on
that one I'll take a few more from in
the room and then I'm sorry we do have
something coming up soon yes there's
been some back and forth about whether
the US has troops in Yemen can you
confirm that we do not have US troops in
Yemen
yeah in the Red Sea in the Gulf of Aiden
the US has carried out preemptive
strikes targeting houie missiles before
they can be launched at International
Shipping is the US going to consider
launching preemptive strikes when it
sees potential attacks on its bases in
Iraq Syria and out Jordan and if not why
not well you've seen um Central Command
take action Dynamic strikes Within
uh the region when we've identified um
when we've been able to identify a
potential uh setup of um of an attack um
or identified a point of origin um so we
have seen some of those Dynamic strikes
in the region and I I'm sorry I don't
have the exact dates when those happened
but they were uh late last year um I'm
not going to get ahead of any decisions
that the secretary and the president are
making on what future action looks like
only to say that we of course uh will
respond when we do yeah take a few more
and then we got it wrap yeah um you
mentioned the uh the Drone impacted the
living quarters um do you have any
details on what what kind of structure
that was is was this kind of a hardened
structure with there a chew a hanger I'm
starting to get a better sense of why it
caused so much damage yeah it was a
contained housing unit that's right just
just one or uh I believe it was just one
that was struck but um you know again
we're still doing our initial
assessments so uh if there's more to
read out we certainly will yes Jeff I
apologize for blurting out a question um
when you had said some of them were in
their beds at the time usually when
there's an indirect fire attack there's
something called the voice of God that
yells incoming incoming incoming take
cover I'm I'm wondering why these
soldiers weren't in the IDF shelter why
they were still in bed yeah it was I
believe early in the morning this is
something that Central Command is
looking into in terms of how the one-way
attack drone was able to get through um
I don't have more details to provide at
this time and when we do we certainly
will will'll let you know okay thanks
everyone sorry we got to
wrap
I